come when I came to Berlin it was the
best city in the world as far as I was
concerned but I really missed the kind
of food I ate in Korea and it was
nothing like what I had at home
youngmee snowden park's family moved to
germany in 1966 she was born in the
German city of volkspark in 1979 after
finishing high school she spent a year
in the South Korean capital Seoul that
helps solidify her Korean roots today
she feels equally at home in both
cultures Germany and South Korea in 2009
young Mei opened a restaurant kimchi
princess in Kreuzberg district of Berlin
although she has a degree from drama
school a friend inspired her to make
cooking her profession at first she sold
her dishes at a local Christmas market
this test phase turned into a huge
success but it took another four years
for youngmee to find the right location
for her concept restaurant I walked by
here and thought it was great and that
it didn't look like a restaurant I fell
in love with it right away despite the
fact that it looked terrible everything
was covered in orange tiles the interior
was completely ugly but the architecture
fascinated me I also liked that it was
on two floors it was love at first sight
even is yeah together with a business
partner
youngmee spent three months renovating
the former nightclub she wanted to
create a Korean restaurant with
authentic food in a sleek and modern
setting that would appeal to an
international clientele in the beginning
she hired a gastronomy expert to help
her implement her ideas
the igloo it was amazing the way it all
developed in the beginning some of my
guests said things like where is Korea
anyhow or what is Korea he had no idea
sometimes I thought take a look at your
cell phone that's actually a South
Korean brand but in the last four years
or so 40 or 50 Korean restaurants have
opened in Berlin it's a great feeling
seeing it become so established the
combis bibimbap is a traditional and
very popular Korean dish it can be made
with vegetables tofu or beef if you use
beef the first step is to prepare a
seasoned marinade
[Music]
the meat should marinate for at least an
hour the word bibimbap literally means
mixed rice which is the base of the dish
then you just add a few of your favorite
toppings
whatever appeals unlike in some Asian
countries in South Korea the rice is
eaten with a spoon chopsticks are only
used for side dishes add kimchi princess
bibimbap is one of the most popular
dishes on the menu it looks wonderful
when it's served and you also get a soup
with it you don't eat the soup first the
way you normally do in Germany the soup
is eaten with the bibimbap another
important thing is that you first season
it with spicy paste and then mix it well
with your spoon many guests are
reluctant to do that because it looks so
pretty and they don't want to ruin it
but it really should be stirred when she
opened her restaurant more than eight
years ago the immediate neighbourhood
didn't have all that many restaurants
many of her friends thought the venture
would fail but the area has since become
trendy
[Music]
kimchee princess was what yang mi's
friends used to call her the nickname is
a reference to kimchi a fermented
cabbage dish that's popular in Korea
when yangmi opened her restaurant she
knew pretty quickly what she wanted to
name it
[Music]
meanwhile she's open to more eateries in
Berlin on a machine and keeping Barbie
to media Smita massacred Sao